[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
game of thrones actress esme bianco sues
singer marilyn manson for alleged sexual
assault
and how much time should derek chovin
spend in prison for the murder of george
floyd
why prosecutors are seeking a higher
sentence and the defense argument for a
lighter term
plus three colorado police officers
resign after video shows the forceful
arrest
of an elderly woman with dementia and
the officers later laughing about it
and a surviving victim takes a stand in
the wisconsin trial
of a man accused of shooting his
ex-girlfriend her family friend
and killing her father i thought i was i
thought i was gone
law and crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmark
co-host terry austin is on assignment
covering the wisconsin trial of joshua
aide
we begin in colorado where three police
officers have resigned
after video released by the attorneys
for an elderly woman with dementia
shows her forceful arrest
attorneys for karen garner say she was
walking home in june 2020
when she was arrested for attempting to
steal 14 worth of items from walmart
why are you fighting with me and why are
you trying to slip the cuffs off
i'm going home body cam video shows
loveland police officer
austin hopp making contact with garner
garner can be heard saying
i'm going home hop pins her arm behind
her back
and then places her in handcuffs i'm
going
home no you're not
all right stand up
after her arrest hop along with officer
daria jalali
and community service officer tyler
blackett can be seen on surveillance
video re-watching the arrest
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
the videos were released by an attorney
for garner who says the 73 year old
woman suffers from dementia
she's now suing the department in
federal court for forcefully arresting
and injuring an elderly woman
according to the lawsuit garner suffered
a broken humorous
dislocated shoulder and sprained wrists
the federal suit also says she did not
receive medical care for six hours
now the police chief says all three
officers are no longer employed by the
department
a spokesperson for the department
confirms the officers resigned on friday
joining us today is civil rights
attorney katie smith and co-founder and
executive director of partners for
justice
emily galvin on monza emily it's not
just that they hurt garner but
how they joked about it afterwards do
you think this case could lead to a
review of the entire department
i think it should um first of all my
compliments to whatever
lawyer thought of requesting that
footage of the officers back at the
station
reviewing this footage because i think
so often we are distracted by
the horrible horrible videos that we see
of the arrest itself
that we forget to think about what
happens afterwards which could really be
revelatory about the culture of this
department the training of this
department
fundamentally though the mechanisms
instilled in police officers given to
police officers are the mechanisms of
violence so yes the dehumanization of
this person is a cultural problem
but will you know more training and
cultural assessments and some sort of
energetic workshop
fix this no it won't they left a woman
with a dislocated shoulder and broken
humerus for six hours without medical
treatment
you can't train someone not to do that
you need a different type of
professional
who is not steeped in a culture of
violence and the tools of violence in
order to
diminish harm katie taking that what
kind of claims could garner argue
against the former officers
and the entire police brian the
department
claims i believe are associated with the
use of force and the denial of access to
medical treatment
so we're looking at excessive force
assault and battery
deliberate indifference to medical
treatment those are
usually both federal and also state law
claims the weaker claims are those
for false arrest because it appears
there's no dispute that there was a
report that she had allegedly stolen
something from a walmart
now whether or not that is true officers
are allowed to arrest people when there
is probable cause
and in most states one person making an
allegation of theft for example would be
enough
for the officers to make an arrest so i
believe more of the force-related claims
are the best
makes sense thank you both now to
california where newly released
body cam video shows officers holding a
man
face down for five minutes before he
lost consciousness and died
almeida police officers approached 26
year old mario gonzalez
on april 19th two callers reported
gonzalez as suspicious to 9-1-1
the police department says the officers
attempted to detain gonzales and a
physical altercation ensued the officers
attempted to place his hands behind his
back
and he suffered a medical emergency
gonzalez's family says he was healthy
and had no known medical conditions an
autopsy is pending
what do you have sorry no it's not that
no
it wasn't that okay
stop stop stop
mario just please stop fighting us
[Music]
we have no weight on his chest
no no no no no wait no wait no way
now there's some similarities between
mario gonzalez and what happened to
george floyd and
ironically enough gonzalez died the day
before derek chovan's conviction
katie what was your reaction to the case
and how does it suit against the
officers looking
in this situation well brian it does
bear the striking similarities to the
chauvin trial and again i think it's
going to bear down to very similar
questions
one causation who actually caused the
death of this man
and number two whether the force used
was excessive
so of course if it is indeed true that
there was a medical emergency that was
not caused by the officers then
obviously we have a
more difficult path to recovery against
the officers but
but logically speaking when you have a
prolonged interaction
with the police there is usually some
causation there
between the force and the death so much
as we've seen in the chauvin trial
really hinges on the medical examiner's
findings and the cause of death
emily was still waiting on that cause of
death in the medical examiner report
but what could accountability look like
in a case like this
so there's accountability for the
officers that we have to think about in
a separate bucket from the right answer
for the community
i'm a lawyer i have to be licensed and i
have to not do a bad job and cause harm
or i lose my license and i don't get to
be a lawyer anymore
i think that officers who do harm to
community members shouldn't get to be
police officers anymore all too often
accountability looks like nothing
or like officers getting to quit their
job in one county and go work in the
next county over and
certainly there's no form of
accountability that's been strong enough
to change the level of police violence
that we're seeing
but i think a better question here is
what does the right solution look like
you know alameda is right next to the
city of oakland where
they've got the new macro program
allowing people to call 9-1-1
and ask for a mental health response
instead of a police response
if you listen to the mental health call
on this case people are calling saying
hey there's a gentleman here
he seems like he might be having a
mental health crisis could we get a
little help they were not asking for a
violent police response
i think the more we utilize programs
like macro
like cahoots and eugene oregon like the
star program in denver
there's actually um legislation pending
right now in state legislature in
california for a 988 number
that would let people specifically call
i mean that's the better answer to this
problem
great call thank you both for that input
still ahead on law and crime daily
one alternative metal star may need his
own personal jesus
after another woman accused him of
sexual assault but first
derek troglin's sentencing date is
getting closer so how long could the
former police officer be behind bars
illegal arguments after this break
welcome back former minneapolis police
officer derek shoven will be sentenced
for the murder of george floyd next
month
anthony levy shows us why the
prosecution wants a harsher sentence
while shoving's team says the law
doesn't allow for it
the sentencing of derek shovin is really
the last big battle to be fought at the
trial court level
and it's no surprise that the
prosecution and the defense
want different things in minnesota
sentences are determined by guidelines
that take into account a defendant's
criminal history
chauvin doesn't have a record so under
the guidelines he would be sentenced to
150 months which is 12 and a half years
but prosecutors want a sentence that
exceeds the guideline
it's called an upward departure they
want possibly as long as 40 years
the judge has the discretion to depart
upward to give a greater sentence
although he does not have to judge peter
cahill will decide whether aggravating
factors existed in this case that would
allow for an upward departure
prosecutors say those factors are george
floyd being particularly vulnerable
they claim that floyd was treated with
particular cruelty and that chauvin
abused his position of authority
the prosecutors go on to say that the
crime was committed
with three or more people and happened
in the presence of children
meanwhile chauvin's attorney argues
against a greater sentence
he says floyd was not particularly
vulnerable because of his size
eric nelson says abuse of a position of
authority is not a recognized
aggravating factor in minnesota
he also says the other defendants
haven't been convicted
and the state has not proven the three
other officers intentionally aided
chauvin in a crime
he also notes the children walking by
and stopping to witness the arrest
is not sufficient grounds for an upward
departure not only would the conviction
itself
be um reviewed by by a court of appeals
but if cahill does depart upward and
give a greater sense
that would also be an issue on appeal
derek chovin is scheduled to be
sentenced
on june 25th for law and crime daily i'm
angenette levy
thanks angenet back with us as
co-founder for partners for justice
emily galvin almanza
and civil rights attorney katie smith
emily former minneapolis police officer
muhammad noor got 12 and a half years
for third degree murder
if that's the benchmark how much should
shovel be getting
so i think when i think about the
factors that we're hearing here i
i believe there's reasonable grounds to
agree with all of the factors listed by
the prosecution
george floyd was treated with particular
cruelty he was particularly vulnerable
i actually think that that definition is
broader because most people at the hands
of violent armed police officers are
especially vulnerable
that being said i also don't believe
that piling on more years in prison
solves anything i
believe in equal justice and i think
that if a black police officer were to
receive dramatically more years than a
white police officer
charged with a similar thing under
similar circumstances that would
evince the racism the structural racism
of this system
that being said think of who you were 12
years ago 12 years is a long sentence i
don't know that piling on more years on
top of that will
bring any form of justice because george
floyd cannot get his life back
and to me that would be the only just
outcome so what we're talking about here
is accountability
accountability for derek chauvin cannot
be achieved through a term of prison
years accountability has to be systemic
and it has to be a transformation of the
way americans are subjected
to our structures of public safety
so i'm not going to answer the
sentencing question i think in a very
direct way
all right i don't think pilate got more
years fixes policing fair enough
i'll come to katie then how do you think
the judge will rule based on the
arguments for a higher sentence
of greater than 150 months man it's a
tough question right and i want to go
around the edges of it myself with this
because i
definitely believe that the aggravating
upper departures are
essentially met in all cases especially
with respect to particular cruelty and
abuse of authority
i believe with the sense of public
outcry and also the fact that he was
guilty in all charges
is going to convince the judge to go a
little bit higher than the 12 and a half
years
agreed that more time doesn't
necessarily solve all these ills
but i think we should expect something a
little higher than the 12 and a half but
not the max
i can see that as well maybe somewhere
around 30 years and be sure to tune in
to the law and crime network this friday
for an hour-long special on the derrick
chauvin trial hosted by anjanet levy
coming up on law and crime daily a
tryout 14 months in the making
the major news for the murder trial of
robert durst ahead
of a coronavirus hiatus plus more
accusations against marilyn manson
why one well-known actress is now suing
the singer in federal court
[Music]
we're back an actress best known for her
role in game of thrones is now suing
marilyn manson
accusing the singer of sexual abuse
court record show esme bianco says
manson engaged in a year-long campaign
of control and abuse against her
according to the complaint manson
attempted to force her to perform sexual
acts
including tying her to a prayer kneeler
beating her with a whip
apparently used by nazis and
electrocuting her manson whose real name
is brian warner
is denying the allegations through his
attorney the lawsuit
filed in california federal court also
names manson's talent manager
as a co-defendant let's bring in civil
rights attorney katie smith and
executive director of partners for
justice emily galvin on monza
emily bianco's allegations are that
manson basically sexually assaulted and
trafficked her
should we be expecting criminal charges
out of this case
that depends on the decision of the l.a
county district attorney and whether
a police report is going to be filed by
anyone in l.a county i think people
forget that the barriers to entry in the
criminal legal system are really
sometimes very simple procedural
barriers i also don't know what the
statute of limitations would be because
it varies based on the charge that the
district attorney would choose so there
may be other legal barriers to a local
case
that being said you know it also depends
on what evidence comes out on the manson
side in federal court
whether there's enough to inspire the
district attorney to move forward or
whether these allegations really are
provably false
all right so we got to see what
allegations come on this federal case
maybe uh katie manson's lawyer is saying
these allegations are provably false
what should we expect next in this case
statute limitations jumps out at me
right away but beyond that provably
false makes
leads me to believe that there's some
evidence that number one these acts were
consensual
or two that they never happened remember
this was a long time ago we're talking
2009 through 2011.
so i expect provably false means we're
going to see some
actual video footage or text messages
something to read about these charges
yeah i would see a consent being a
strong argument here for the defense
by the description of some of the scars
uh if there are scars there then that
would be hard to show
anything but consent but we'll see how
that plays out when we come back
a woman allegedly shot by her
ex-boyfriend and survived takes the
stand against him
the testimony you don't want to miss
next
[Music]
welcome back the long crime network is
set to be the only camera in the
courtroom
when the highly anticipated murder trial
of robert durst resumes later this month
the new york real estate air is accused
of killing his best friend
susan berman in her los angeles home in
december 2000.
durst trial had three days of openings
and 10 witnesses take the stand
before covet 19 postponed the trial on
march 12
2020. the trial judge has repeatedly
denied motions by the defense to declare
a mistrial
over the 14-month long adjournment the
trial could last
up to six months live capital gavel
coverage begins on may 17th
and the latest trial on the law and
crime network is underway terry austin
is here to tell us
more about the state of wisconsin versus
joshua aide
aide a resident of the state was charged
back in august with murdering
his ex-girlfriend's father james
groutnier
aide is also charged with two counts of
attempted murder for shooting his
ex-girlfriend
rebecca burkowski and family friend john
miller police say aide was dating his
girlfriend five years before she called
it quits in march
2020. according to court records text
messages show his
ex wanted him to remove a broken down
car
from her property i was standing next to
john
we were looking over the radiator so
if the radiator is in front of me and
i'm looking at the hood
john was standing to my right and the
next thing i knew
there was josh um at first he just kind
of i just kind of looked at him
and he said hey boo what you doing
and i went to turn i didn't say anything
to him i just went to turn because i was
starting to put tools away i had a 10
millimeter socket in my hand and i had
turned to the left so put that in to the
toolbox
there was a laser pointed in the middle
of my forehead
and i said what the fuck josh
he had fired he tried to fire when that
laser was on the middle of my forehead
and he missed and i was able to move
just enough and um the next thing i knew
as i was
falling um i kept saying i was flying
i really i thought i was i thought i was
gone i just i was
i fell and and the next thing i knew
i was on my side i had woken up and i
had seen
a police officer next to my dad's ford
focus
and my eyes shifted to the right and
that's where i saw my dad laying
i remember saying help
i remember my dad wasn't moving
but i i had also just spoken out for
come too and i was
vomiting and my my ear was ringing
and of course that was rebecca burkowski
the most important witness in this case
she is one of the victims who was shot
in the ear
you heard her testify it was her
ex-boyfriend
who is on trial joshua aide
thanks terry emily and katie are here
now to break down the aid trial
katie i know that we all swoon for a
good opening statement but what did you
think of the defense skipping it in this
case
you're right brian every time i wait for
that opening statement
to soak up what exactly the defense is
going to do and i
like you brian tend to swoon over a very
solid opening statement so the fact that
one was not made
leads me to believe the defense isn't
sure what the prosecution's going to put
that there
there or they don't know what they're
going to put out there it's puzzling
though
in a case of an affirmative defense if
you're going for
a reason of insanity or self-defense you
would want to put that out there in an
opening statement so
we will see what is yet to come emily on
motion papers
the defense kind of put out there that
this is a self-defense case do you see
that or is something missing
well in order to prove self-defense you
need somebody some form of evidence
usually in the form of witness testimony
saying it was self-defense now let's
think about who was there
um two of the people are complainants in
this case one person
is deceased the only person who can
really make it a self-defense case
is mr aide if he chooses to take the
stand and so i could see a very good
argument for his lawyer
choosing to reserve their opening not
put their facts on the record because
they haven't decided yet whether they're
going to be able to poke holes in the
prosecution case
or whether mr aide himself could have to
testify in order to put up
some form of defense and create a
self-defense case
so just really quickly emily are you
anticipating that joshua aide will
testify
in this case then i think it's
impossible to anticipate i don't even
think mr aide himself knows that it's
one of the single most high stakes
decisions
that a person accused of a crime can
have to make i think it's probably going
to be a game time decision i assume that
his team is prepping him extensively
right now in case he needs to testify
but i doubt they've made the call yet
all right we'll see how that works out
thank you both for joining us and thank
you for joining us here at long crime
daily
we'll see you next time as we discuss
justice in america
[Music]
you